face Quiditch story with eyes Pasbon Phi car
make station
1 person sos powder define security service system e re
anta dare to do over
We human beings are creatures destined to walk together with technology, isn't it?
You use anchor scooper good up to do
3rd floor 4 cycles I say
scientists in the fields of robots and 5 fields of trial
Pou dou dou
No Ponti When a
person tries to move his body, he gets a command to turn his body back with his brain.
This is the command.
It will be a robot for such treatment as going
.
Distec Azy House p minutes old and mouse 2
p board Thermicas Aqua I had a second brain bleeding in 2011
.  The reason why I could see the light of hope was that my dad would
become a mother robot
. When I told him to do a robot, I would definitely cap it, but there are many
bankruptcies that robots can walk around here.
Even if I walk the dog, I'm walking around.
If I hadn't met in the spring,
I would have had a
harder time.  I also expect that robots will move forward as a new pioneer area
.
What kind of technology will determine the future of humankind?